hey guys Ryan right here dance a bird
here we're gonna watch a little game
trailer game trailer for a game called
alien isolation yes now if I'm correct
on this information Dan yeah it deals
with the alien movie franchise now
there's been a lot of speculation but so
far rumors are yes it is career it is
just totally [ __ ] no idea what is
related to the Alien franchise oh cool
just a quick little background the
previous aliens game to come out
colonial Marines was a huge flop mom so
but from hopefully what we're hearing
and seeing from this game it's gonna be
great
okay I'm down with that yeah I just got
a lot more excited did you really [ __ ]
fortune teller fortune telling as in you
could read the title yeah and then make
a good guess of it well done I think
we're done here
alright let's check this out let's do it
baby
18 thank you okay hmm that's actually
important to know oh I love the old
school mister yeah it's got that nice
late eighties field
I'm Sam Mills I work for the company I'm
Mel Gibson I probably not
it's about your mother
this is game
there's that here we you were talking
about there's that blood you were
expecting
we got to shut the book Ripley
oh is it so it's like based on the first
alien movie that's that's the idea how
cool you get it being Ripley shoes I'm
not sure exactly when and where it's
supposed to take place but it definitely
has the feel of like the old movie yeah
because it looked like the original
spaceship and stuff yeah how neat
now it says in-game and it all looks
really great but they have said that
before and it ended up looking really
shitty afterwards so it's like you have
to take this like a little grain of salt
sure there'll be some redemption they
put into their work here I would
certainly hope so
let's hope they do some games don't do
that no I love the idea of just being in
like Ripley shoes finally you know cuz
I'm not I haven't played India in I
haven't played in any oh my god it's
okay
take it easy buddy I haven't played any
of the other alien games but I have a
feeling they're not from Ripley's point
of view mm-hmm yeah different things it
doesn't quite clarify but it seems like
it is and that would be cool if it is
what I really enjoy from it is that some
of the other alien games so far are kind
of had that sort of Call of Duty feel to
it where it's just like yeah you have a
frickin gun now good yeah this one is
capturing more of that horror s yes
which is why I'm personally excited to
dive back into this whole series yeah
because the first Alien movie was the
one that really had that down like
there's a monster on the loose here
granted in space and I love that type of
vibe because aliens was great you know
that was it like but that's more like a
sci-fi action thriller it's back to
being feeling suspenseful yeah it always
seems like those sort of like sci-fi
horror sort of things always start like
if they have sequels it starts like Ron
like scary and then eventually just ends
do well everyone grab a gun yeah we're
gonna be okay and gonna solve everything
but no I think that's a message the kid
sure here
kids remember guns are our best friends
and if parents are mad at me for saying
that if I have that much influence over
your child you were a bad parent
and if it doesn't upset you we're glad
you've joined the NRA well guys thanks
for telling me about this trailer I love
the Alien franchise you know what I do
actually I even like the shitty ones
really alien 3 and Alien Resurrection
hmm how would even even mind if they
made it part 5
don't say Prometheus okay well if you're
new to the channel uh hit this button up
here it's ready to subby scribe please
it's cool and right down here is Dan's
gaming channel wow that's cyber Channel
there's a lot of cool things up there
and if you're if you saw that playlist
up right of if people are new to your
channel I have it I have a playlist for
if you're new and if and if you are new
and want to keep watching though some of
my stuff [ __ ] that up
yeah do it again do it again oh yeah I
have my playlist for all of you that are
come the new to my channel and I hope
that you enjoyed that and I have a bunch
of videos coming up this week Tuesdays
and Thursdays is one I usually post I'm
doing em Niva right now which is my
Wednesday post so I don't do horror well
so it's spooky scary and I cry what
about this game is it are you gonna be
able to handle that mmm you gonna be
able to handle this game ah I think I
think so
okay I think I might be alright I'm
building up a tough skin but uh who
knows they were doing the jack-offs I'm
getting the great
well guys he waited a good five minutes
to finally get around to this part of
the video well done
shoutout time what first person on the
agenda crazy like curry he um he just
sub him that's awesome
he said love your reactions awesome well
curry you love my reactions facts and
you're okay with mine mmm-hmm and that's
better than usual for me thanks curry
thanks great that it
what's your photo dude are you a ninja
he looks like a ninja or terrorist who
Danny
did Ryan just cross the line never no
such thing is a line for right I checked
I took tons of scientific research there
is no line for Ryan mystic Knight 23000
that's much I was actually yeah so jokes
Ryan I love your videos man I think
you're nearly there with Jeremy John's
I'm assuming that would be very kind of
you that's for you man and can I please
get a shout-out because you you rock man
keep it up well dude thank you thank you
if you're comparing me to Jeremy John's
no man is better than Jeremy Jones truth
also did scientific research yeah
figured it out if there's one person I
can't cross its Jeremy Jones also mystic
Knight
thank you for making me street safe cuz
he's the bad man he's a Bevin thumbnail
the mystic Batman mystic Batman
thumbnail hey could you fire the
thumbnail Devin Harris hi please give me
a shout-out you guys are funny
well he did it right he said please
thank you read it us versus it hi and
he's asked for a shout-out but then he
didn't just leave it there he wanted to
give us a compliment yes saying you guys
are funny mm-hmm very good that is the
correct way to ask for a shout-out that
we as possible we appreciate you it's
efficient it's not a little paragraph
and it's not just too short you use the
right choice of words Devin you must
have good parents
unlike taught you well yeah unlike those
parents who equip their kids with guns
because their children wanted guns and
they thought this was the solution
because some idiot on YouTube told them
it was okay unless you do have a gun and
are with the NRA